jabe is all too familiar with the
problem of drug use at school she says
it nearly ruined her life
it was scary I could have lost
everything you know I wouldn't have I
would have just sat in my room for the
rest of my life doing drugs and that
isn't a life that I want to live I want
I'm a teenager I meant to be out there
enjoying my life and you can't when
you're smoking weed all the time she's
not gonna happen
now Sky News has obtained figures
suggesting Jade story is far from
isolated 1149 pupils have been caught
with drugs at UK schools in the past
three years most of them with Class B
although 27 were found with Class A
drugs 93 pupils were charged for drug
offences over the three years including
six at primary schools the figures come
from thirty two of the UK's 44 police
forces and do not include some of the
largest such as the Met and Greater
Manchester Police at this London school
there's recognition that drug abuse is a
problem the most privileged pupils are
equally likely to encounter quite
daunting the fact that I could be
offered drugs over the next three to
five years and just you know it sort of
leads me to think you know what will I
say great will I be pressured head
teacher Chris Godwin says drug education
in line with government policy to reduce
demand for illegal substances law is
critical we live in a society where I
speak to a lot of teenagers they're in
situations where they know that there
are drugs available I think the key is
not to lose sight of constantly
educating the pupils and there's concern
that the age at which children are using
drugs is getting younger and younger at
this cannabis factory dealers admitted
supplying to primary school-aged
children this charity which works with
vulnerable children is increasingly
encountering younger drug users what
we're now seeing is that eight nine year
olds are beginning to smoke weed and
then they and skunk and then they go on
- harder stuff later on a lot of them
there's real concern about the impact
drugs are having on all aspects of
children's lives and as the new figures
prove school is no exception
fo Hirsch Steiners